lorient 8e de ligue à tours 12e de l'ipl
affiches annonces et promesses dans le
crachin breton du stade du moustoir
iv nous mettons
marquer en contre par ce tir trop croisé
mais ce bout
merci
on a tous les mêmes
c
un début d'année fertile en buts en
bretagne d'abord une parade
du tout
les minutes
il faut tourner la page
bibi à la france en cinquième
la spéculation
mais de mieux développer cette cette
dernière phase roues voilà un secret on
se crée encore secret encore aujourd'hui
beaucoup de situations mais on a marqué
seulement deux buts
je pense qu'il y avait la place pour
marquer 3 4 buts même s'il était
possible
pourrais tu nous tiens
tour à tour
réforme
oui